so
all right
same thing
still in your shoulder
if i speed it up
it's not going to be good okay
right hey
okay
your
on limb
strength
that's resistant
your chemi is on center expansion
okay
and
you're coming in and you're moving the
center so this is kind of just giving
you one little opening the elbow is now
more effective in moving the center
directly that's taking the other one but
you don't want to make it an arm
technique you created a
movement now for the body to be directly
influenced so don't travel and make this
arm geometry a leverage technique
you want to think of it more as a hip
room
okay
so
slide opening
continuing the opening on the elbow and
once you have it you're moving in
through the center
dude
okay so you find the archer not the
arrow
that's why i don't do the the arm
okay
if i if i'm coming
she tries to grab my arm and do an arm
bar go ahead
i'm just gonna sit here it's very hard
to control arms on someone who doesn't
wanna have their arm control
you're removing center
you're attacking center okay
if i'm going into the center i'm not
going to go into the center and then
come back and try and get that arm again
i prioritize the archer
not the arrow
okay
so the same thing
if she tries to prioritize she's got the
body here and now let's say she goes to
do the arm again just the arm
so hard where
it's not gonna work okay
it tends to work because uke in the
aikido culture just lays
takes a rest
but if you look at me
there is nothing
holding me
still to this position in the mouth you
see
so as she pulls the arm
i can move any number of ways
okay
my uk is always just so happy to lay
down that it works
my goal tactically is to come in
oh she's the one
her arm just happens to be
in the way
so i have to deal with it
if her arm collapse
boom
okay
neon stomach do what i have to do
there's no reason to go out
so she has to give me
a reason and that's the arm
okay
i can't pull it because then i evaluate
that first tactical consideration so i
go in
and around it
and that's what makes them
follow this
boom
in bring your foot in to see if it's
mushy and i can keep attacking when it's
not mushy then i go around it
so my pattern is
in
continue in i feel oh obstacle did i go
around it
down i go
all right
foreign
so i'm not doing the uh
you know the
the damn sheehan
oh
no
you know what i mean they like don't
give you any of the technique
okay
i gave him that
it's not quite there is it
right because he has to have his face
i'm giving it to him
i'm just doing whatever he's doing so
let's do that he saw me through a little
step right
because he only took about four inches
of entry put your foot back
if he answers that much
he's not going to push me over that leg
so he just i'm just doing what he's
doing push
he got a little
okay but not all my center right of
course i can bring my leg back in but
he's not not here to
subvert everything he's doing okay
so he's going out a little bit so you
see my center didn't move all i did was
move my arm right right so that's all i
do he goes
you gotta figure out how to move me
a little bigger
a little better
it's not this or
or this
okay
let them learn
there i'm going to get my body to move
all right so
that angle doesn't work right
why don't you watch i'm gonna help you
why don't you stop
why don't you roll this this way
your safe situation waiting for your
show
nope forward
now you're coming in and what you're
going to end up doing
is you're going to push
go ahead and position that okay so i
would have the arm right just position
that and the leg is up
okay and all you're going to do is push
this over and all they have to do is hop
back in that position
what you want to do instead
is that go to topsy-turvy effect that we
always do so it's the same geometry of
the forward roll she has to be on the
diagonal and the feet have to travel
in
contrast to the head on that diagonal
okay
so if you look at when she does a
forward roll this hip can't be down
this tip
to follow that same path i just did with
the head and feet this tip has to go
around that way
you understand so if i do the arm bar
look i put that hip down
you see and now i just have arm control
that's all i have and if you're strong
enough and if they don't mind lying down
for you it works but you shouldn't train
for people that you're stronger and
people who don't mind you
right
so what you have to do is you have to
leave that hip open
you have to get your hip in there
before
it closes
okay
if you exaggerate it
and we'll close that hip all the way
with a step forward
that hips closed all the way do you see
that that is the
opening
you don't do a motif
when that foot goes forward because the
hips closed all the way
and if you find that you close that hip
all the way
here you should do
an ura
variation don't come in promote or
you're violating the first tenant which
is you're fighting the arrow and not the
archer so that hip cannot be closed
that means don't push this arm so far
forward
try to look what i'm doing instead i'm
holding it
i'm positioning her
on my hip
and then i use the arm
to do what i was doing with that push of
her head and foot
that creates
the topsy-turvy effect
that gives her me the opening
pool onto her center
versus fighting her chasing her down
this way at an angle
the move is over boom now it's happening
okay
so
why am i pinning the person
why
let's just make a kind of
tactical
capturing of time and space
and i could think i had a little i know
it's a pin why am i painting them
okay
i can't throw them and they can't attack
anymore
so let's look at that
for one at a time like they can't attack
anymore
in that question
it doesn't seem to to
ask nor answer
why do you pin versus throw
or strike
is it not true that if i throw or strike
or choke out
some other thing that i can also achieve
not them not attacking anymore
okay
so
when i now ask the question
why am i pinning them i'm kind of in an
unsaid way asking why am i not throwing
them why am i not striking them why am i
not choking them
okay
to achieve these tactical ends
so i'll ask that question again but
you're going to hear me unsaid why am i
pinning them
and you said because you can't throw
them
okay
uh
why can't i throw them
um
i guess because they're
in some way hindering the architecture
or weapons you need in order to throw
them okay so well
so so then in your reasoning there's an
assumption between that that's in place
i'm not saying it's wrong but there's an
assumption that
i do select one
means whether it be striking pain
choking etc
against another
because one is better suited
for whatever ends i want than the other
ones are and better suited we will just
for the sake of mouth
uh define it just more efficient
okay or more possible or a higher
percentage of achievement
okay are you fine with that all right so
why can't i throw them specifically what
is in the way of me throwing them
do i not have to move them to pin them
so that's not it
is it that they've presented a threat to
you that you have to address before you
came
tonight you froze against presented to
me so that's not it
is even closer and that's a throw
well if you if you by doing the
technique okay and i come in here
without a problem
do you qualify that as a throw
is it that maybe you tried to throw but
they were still
there so to speak they're still
connected to you
from i would say that's on the right
track okay
because i am attempting to throw
there's tactical advantages to throwing
over penny
right one is
i'm not close
i have to be close to be injured
behind why we moved from sword fighting
to firearms you don't have to be close
anymore and why we go from firearms to
missiles yeah i can be far away and why
and why we go from
jet fighters to drones the pilot is even
further away
okay it's not even with the weapons
so i have to be close in order to be
injured so
tactically that would mean
throwing is a pretty good option
which would mean pinning has to come
after the fact
and if i think about a little bit it's
easier to pin somebody who's falling
than it is to force someone down from a
standing
position okay
and i also know from my trapping
training that it's hard as hell
to catch an arm when someone doesn't
want your arm their arm caught
in in aikido
arms are there all the time for you
okay
and in real life they're moving
they're moving either to hit you they're
moving to pull out of their out of your
grip
or they're just moving because the
person is trying to keep their own
balance
and due to their own personal history
which you have no exposure to because
they're not a okay that you train with
all your life right or ten years or five
years
they put their arms wherever they want
so the arm is moving
the idea of catching this arm in mid
space for you to pin is just ludicrous
and what i find when in in the in
training law enforcement that's one of
the biggest things
that causes the kink in the in what
they're trying to do
they're trying to control this arm which
is hard as hell to control
and it doesn't matter how big or small
the person is the damn thing's moving
okay so
if i have the idea that i'm supposed to
fight her not the arm
and if i have the idea that i am aware
how hard it is to trap arms and to
control arms that don't want to be
people either intentionally or
unintentionally
okay
and i know that i'm
i'm going to move in on them
and i know that it's better
to get them away from me than to tighten
them up close
and let the ground do its ballistic
damage and effect on their body
why do i do this because the arm is
there so my grip is not a dead grip
you're going 20 minutes if you saw the
couple reps
your hands are just checking the elbow
so as i come in i'm just checking the
elbow so to speak
okay
and then that arm is still there and
iron's still here
you got it she did not go flying away
this arm did not collapse so i can't
come into the center but she's right on
me so the other arm can grab and
so i'm going to use this now
but not in a let me grab the arm weight
just in a way of closing off
that shoulder
so i don't like to see your echo
like this
tactically inferior
archer coming into the center
you see now i realize oh we're close and
i go around the energy
then here i have a coke you repetition
okay heaviness settle body organization
it's not a pin
nobody's gonna stay there because you
did that on their arms
okay it's true he's got a lot of you got
a lot of other
he's got a lot of unnecessary tension
okay
but
when you coming around
again don't don't point that hip down
your hip has to be in front
okay
oh no that's too much giving up
it'll be about there
okay
my goal is
to come in
this is where everything is
okay
this is where the back mount
right where we were
okay
it's forward
you see how that damn arm is still there
right
so
i'm here
i'm gonna come in
oh nope i didn't get him but the damn
arm is still there
that's how i do
okay
that's all the opening you need
underneath
move straight in there's that arm and i
bring it around
you guys still want this arm so bad
i'd rather have his face
any questions
comment we didn't talk about everything
it's just
some of the things you were saying about
doing this technique
these tend to be the common problem
areas
most people because most people haven't
asked
even those few questions we asked why am
i doing that
why not this
okay
what is my assumption what is the ending
so i kind of breathed over right the
ending i told you not a thing
what did i call it
yeah it's a cokey repetition it's just
working on coke you you will not paint
anybody
by holding their
arm down like that
so i know that
just like that
you'll have people who will like turn
the arm
and this person is very sensitive to
pain usually and so they go ah
and they don't move
okay
or you'll have people will do another
pain thing over here with the wrist okay
and again they they are sensitive to
pain most
aikido practitioners and so
they tap out
but
that would make it a pain compliance
move
okay
it would be no different in essence if i
pull her hair
meaning she wants me to stop hurting her
so that's why she's i'm actually picking
the head up aren't i
okay
there's nothing there so if we go
there's there's nothing there at all
that stops me
from
turning over
there's because pins work in the dynamic
fashion
the idea that you're going to stop
reality once and for all and hold it
still
isn't that kind of strange
once i start moving at all i change the
geometry so right now she's got her
weight under her right
but
now does she
no i'm starting to move i'm starting to
move it
getting down as hard as you can
donate come push your shoulders down
okay oh that's heavy
i just moved it okay
and in that ability to move it
the effectiveness of the pin is gone
and that allows me to move more parts of
my body
you see and once i do that i i start to
deconstruct the pin even more even more
even more even more
pins and locks are just moments in time
space
and you should think of them as
a kind of controlling of a larger
portion of mass or a smaller portion of
that
that's what an opinion is
it's not a permanent fixture
okay
so that means there should be a pinning
element in my
nugget too
because i should be controlling a
smaller part to move a larger part
got it
okay so if i have that assumption i see
this goofy ass
thing at the end
i should be asking what is that about
what's going on there because nobody in
their right mind would ever think that
that's an actual pin and by right mind i
mean a person who actually studied a
question
and theorized and reflected upon what is
pending
you see no one ever do that or somebody
who attempted to do it in real life if
with enough times against resistant
people
they too
would go that does not work
but the person who doesn't see it
through doesn't then ask
what is it for them
what is a pin they just go like here it
doesn't work
or back pain doesn't work
it's not that's not it's just that
wasn't a pin at all
but that call q organization
i do use that in pinning
if once i understand what opinion is
then i do use that when i bring that
pinion element into my nagawaza
i now see that that is the best way of
practicing what pinning truly is
okay
it's kind of like that thing i posted
today about the argument part of the
genie if you haven't seen that yet if
you were truly interested in that
question
you wouldn't stop there you wouldn't say
it sucks
you would try and figure out what what
any questions
okay since i've noticed
i feel like
i don't like timing
where
i would ski
but i wouldn't i wouldn't use
i wouldn't time this step with the ski
and so when we were doing it to like
push each other back it was all alarmed
what the heck is this and then later by
the time i showed them how to like get i
guess more of a timing stuff more
driving it with my body and i feel like
i'm also translating into
my nugget was it like some time is wrong
or something i'm moving incorrectly to
where
so remember where i told you uh you were
working with jake and i said you've got
to stay up so that the arm would be
there remember that correction
okay so that meant
that you're out of the technique you're
far but i said stay up that means you're
not staying up that means you're out of
the city okay
the reason you're out of the technique
is because you're using a different
mechanical organization to move jade
right you're using one where you push
against
him with your hands
versus one where
you push against the ground
and because you moved
he moved all right so that that looks
like this give us some room okay
okay so
here like this and this is you see my
bracing angle okay and
you start to
your arms start to lengthen okay well
the unsaid resultant of that is that
your body is moving further away so if i
start to bend my arms you see how much
closer i am to her so when i extend my
arms like that i'm moving things further
from me okay
this if you look at my body i have a
bracing angle
that's no difference when we do the coq
training elements and you're doing this
which now becomes exposed when she lets
go fast
you'll fall forward same kind of thing
across the ground you come like this and
if they fall forward
fall forward you kind of
do that stumbling which you also do
right
okay so
it doesn't matter if you're doing it on
this step or if you're doing it on this
step
it's still going to be the same okay so
what's happening is that you're using
your feet as a bracing angle to push
your shoulders into them
right
versus
grounding
so i'm here
and i'm grounding under the back foot
so the back foot is going to move please
try to stay with him
the back foot
is pushing my body
not my falling
the back foot is pushing my body the
front foot please can you feel your
balance forward
okay the back foot is pushing
then the front here's where you stop and
you start to get a bracelet but i'm
going to push
onto the front foot which is now squishy
so when you do the joe drills
and she's she's representing the
resistance okay
if i try to do that against that body
and i try to walk i'll never get past
this foot
it's a weak point
the more i bring the foot forward the
more i fall back i have to shift weight
from this foot
pull
onto this foot
so i can walk
this way
no
i have to shift
shift
shift if she let's go at any moment
okay
so you
you're not grounded you're pushing
okay
don't touch the camera